[Aplausos]
[Música]
no sé si alguna vez os lo habéis
preguntado pero desarrollar un nuevo
modelo de avión es probablemente una de
las tareas empresariales más complejas
que existen
[Música]
las dificultades que entraña el proceso
no sólo tienen que ver con la enorme
carga tecnológica que tienen los aviones
de hoy en día sino también con las
estrictas regulaciones a las que se
tienen que ceñir regulaciones que en
ocasiones pueden chocar colisionar con
los tiempos de puesta en servicio de
nuevos aviones y amigos este este podría
ser precisamente el caso del infame
boeing 737 max puesto en servicio
comercial en mayo de 2017
[Música]
este nuevo modelo se creó para sustituir
a los actuales modelos 737
next-generation y competir contra su
equivalente europeo el airbus a 320 n o
ambos aviones tanto el 737 max como el a
320 neo forman parte de una nueva
hornada de aviones más eficientes más
silenciosos y menos contaminantes
[Música]
sin embargo el fabricante estadounidense
de aeronaves boeing pudo haber cometido
un enorme terrible error en sus
decisiones empresariales simple y
llanamente para poder competir contra
airbus a tiempo ya que su modelo a3 20n
o se había puesto en servicio un año y
medio antes en enero del 2016
[Música]
es decir las prisas podrían haber sido
las causantes de dos terribles desastres
que todavía tenemos grabados en la
retina
ah
poco más de un año después de la entrada
en servicio del 737 max el 29 de octubre
de 2018 el vuelo 610 de lionel se
estrellaba poco después de despegar del
aeropuerto psoe karno de yakarta
indonesia el vuelo iba lleno y ninguno
de sus 189 pasajeros sobrevivió
y
pero si ya parecía extraño que se
estrella es un avión nuevo con menos de
tres meses
sí sí tres meses de uso todas las
alarmas saltaron por los aires pocas
semanas después el 29 de marzo de 2019
otro boeing 737 max 8 de la compañía
ethiopian airlines se estrelló también
poco después de despegar del aeropuerto
de voley en etiopía así es amigos
estamos ante dos accidentes muy
parecidos en la misma fase del vuelo el
despegue del mismo modelo de avión el 77
max y ambos sin supervivientes en apenas
cuatro meses el nuevo y deslumbrante
modelo de point se había cobrado 346
vidas
[Música]
con semejante situación la
administración federal de aviación de
los estados unidos- la efe
ordenó la paralización inmediata de toda
la flota de 737 max en el país y le
recomendó al resto de agencias de
seguridad aéreas del mundo que hicieran
exactamente lo mismo
[Música]
en cuestión de horas todos los aviones
de este modelo habían sido detenidos y
estacionados en aeropuertos a lo largo y
ancho de todo el mundo sin saber cuándo
podrían volver a volar imaginaos el caos
que todo esto supuso miles y miles
decenas de miles de billetes tuvieron
que ser cancelados
y amigos lo que iba a ser algo temporal
se alarga hasta nuestros días porque
estos aviones siguen sin poder volar
[Música]
y ahora conociendo los hechos que es el
momento de hacernos unas cuantas
preguntas qué pasó para que se
estrellaran esos dos vuelos cómo y por
qué se aprobó la operativa de un avión
con estos problemas que ha supuesto este
desastre para el gigante boeing y las
compañías aéreas que compraron el modelo
atentos
[Música]
perisic al destino del autor safety car
62 en fly no en balde
un sistema de seguridad inseguro para
entender rápidamente qué es lo que ha
sucedido con los 737 max hace falta
conocer cuáles fueron los principales
cambios que se hicieron respecto al
modelo anterior del 77 el 737
next-generation
[Música]
en el caso de lugo max se equipó al
avión con motores completamente nuevos
mucho más eficientes silenciosos y
también bastante más grandes por este
motivo por el tamaño y el peso de los
nuevos motores tuvieron que hacer un
apaño para poder colocarlos de forma que
no rozasen con el suelo en ciertas
circunstancias ya que los 737 tienen la
panza mucho más cerca del suelo que sus
homólogos europeos los a 320 y si no me
creéis fijaos en esta imagen de un
boeing 737 ng el anterior modelo y el a
320 juntos
[Música]
ahora bien puede que muchos os estáis
preguntando para alberto tan importantes
todo esto pues sí sí que lo es fijaos
para poder incorporar los nuevos motores
del 737 max tuvieron que ingeniar dos
soluciones primero crearon un nuevo
sistema de tren de aterrizaje para que
el avión quedase más separado del suelo
al aterrizar
[Música]
y segundo y aquí viene lo problemático
tuvieron que adelantar y elevar la
posición de los motores ligeramente por
delante de las alas para separarlos del
suelo y esto esto cambió por completo el
centro de gravedad del avión
[Música]
para que nos entendamos al cambiar el
centro de gravedad del avión en los
despejes y ascensos iniciales este
modelo es mucho más proclive a entrar en
pérdida y que es una pérdida pues una
pérdida quiere decir que el avión pierde
sustentación por una velocidad escasa
para ascender y cuando se ocurre con un
avión entra en pérdida y empieza a caer
a plomo
[Música]
aunque eso es algo conocido y los
pilotos están entrenados para corregirlo
el caso que para solucionar este
problema ya diseño que hace que el 77
máx sea proclive traen perdida boeing
crea un sistema llamado mc a ese en
español sistema de aumentos de
características de maniobra
[Música]
así para evitar que el avión caiga este
sistema corrige automáticamente el
cabeceo del avión si detecta una posible
situación de pérdida en el ascenso pero
como lo corrigió
[Música]
pues bien la forma más común de salir de
una perdida es bajando el morro del
avión para recuperar velocidad y con
ella la sustentación por eso el sistema
forzaba al avión a descender tratando de
evitar anticipadamente una perdida
[Música]
el problema era que a veces lo hacía
demasiado pronto sin altura suficiente
para esa corrección y con una deficiente
comunicación con los sensores exteriores
de la aeronave
es decir que el software lanzaba hacia
abajo los aviones lo que podría pasar
después ya lo sabéis fue precisamente lo
que le ocurrió en esos dos vuelos
accidentados
[Música]
ahora bien mucho seguro que estaréis
pensando vale pero si nosotros hacemos
esto lo tendrían que saber los lotos
antes de ponerse a los mandos de estos
aviones no pues no muchos pilotos del
modelo ni siquiera sabían que este
sistema existía otros muchos no sabían
cómo desactivarlo porque el sistema
funciona incluso con el piloto
automático desconectado
[Música]
y aquí amigos aquí es donde comienza una
tórrida historia sobre la seguridad la
transparencia y las condiciones en las
que se aprobó este avión queréis saber
cómo continuar atentos
[Música]
se podría haber evitado el desastre
amigos estamos ante una historia de
película
i
durante los últimos meses no han dejado
de aparecer noticias informes documentos
que apuntan a una posible falta de
supervisión de la fe a estadounidense en
la aprobación el boeing 737 max
lo que se suma a posibles negligencias
en las que boyle podría haber incurrido
por las prisas en lanzar el avión sólo
hay que echar un vistazo a los correos
internos de los empleados donde se
decían cosas como es un avión diseñado
por payasos a su vez supervisado por
monos pondrías a tu familia en un avión
entrenado con el simulador max yo no lo
haría ahora bien podrían quizás haberse
evitado los dos accidentes del máx pues
bien informaciones recientes apuntan a
que si peter defazio jefe del comité de
transporte de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu asegura que hay
más de medio millón de documentos emails
y entrevistas de boeing y la efe ha
recopilados en su panel que apuntan a
una ruptura de la cultura de la
seguridad entre boeing y la efe
nuestra investigación ha revelado que
muchos de los propios expertos técnicos
e inspectores de seguridad de la
administración federal de aviación creen
que la gerencia de este organismo a
menudo se pone del lado de boeing en
lugar de defender la seguridad de la
gente
peter defazio vamos tiene que ser un
lince para darse cuenta de que lo que
quiere decir de fazio entre líneas es
que boyle y la efe
colaboraron para relajar los
requerimientos y así acelerar los
tiempos de aprobación del modelo
el motivo bueno quizás como ya hemos
dicho que el bus hubiera lanzado el a
320 n o tuviera algo que ver pero amigos
esto no termina aquí para nada hay más
muchísimo más
[Música]
después del primer accidente el de
lionel efe
concluyó que el mc a ese era la causa
del siniestro y anticipó que de no
solucionar el problema con este sistema
podrían producirse hasta 15 accidentes
similares durante la vida útil de la
flota
[Música]
dicho con otras palabras el 737 max era
mucho más proclive a estrellarse que
todos los modelos de boeing actualmente
en servicio juntos
[Música]
esa era la previsión y ojo porque el
tiempo nos ha mostrado que la realidad
podría ser mucho peor si tenemos en
cuenta el corto periodo de actividad de
este modelo los datos son demoledores
haciendo una regla de 3 el 737 max la
nueva estrella de boeing tendría dos
accidentes catastróficos por cada millón
de vuelos mientras que por ejemplo su
predecesor el 737 next-generation cuenta
con una estadística de un accidente por
cada 10 millones de vuelos esto es 20
veces menos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para que os hagáis una idea la media de
accidentes fatales de todos los
fabricantes a nivel mundial es de uno
por cada tres millones de vuelo esto
supone seis veces menos que el máx es
decir por si no ha quedado claro con
estas estadísticas el máx tendría más
accidentes que un avión hecho por
fascículos
[Música]
boeing fabricó un avión deficiente eso
es un hecho a día de hoy a ver es que
sabiendo esto te subiría estuvo un avión
de estos tranquilo yo desde luego que no
pues ojo porque la efe aa estadounidense
pensó de forma diferente al menos tras
el primer accidente
y amigos tras descubrir las tremendas
deficiencias del sistema ms literalmente
tiro el avión de lionel contra el suelo
este organismo se limitó a verter toda
la responsabilidad sobre las
tripulaciones si lo habéis escuchado
bien
[Música]
a efe a le dió a boeing siete meses para
modificar e instalar en todos los máx
del mundo una nueva versión de lmc a ese
sin error es decir se permitió que boyle
hiciera un remedio mediante software un
parche temporal hasta que resolviera el
fallo de diseño que evidentemente no
podía llegar a todos los aviones a la
vez
[Música]
por este motivo las tripulaciones de los
aviones no actualizados fueron avisadas
de que volaban en aviones con un mc a
ese que podría estrellar el avión contra
el suelo
y con este aviso y una formación
supuestamente para saber cómo pelearse
contra este sistema en caso de fallo es
decir en caso de que el sistema lanzara
de nuevo un avión hacia abajo cuando aún
se encontrase a poca distancia del suelo
la efe ha creído que los aviones podían
seguir en servicio
no tiene pinta de ser la mejor decisión
no os parece que de hecho no fue a la
vista está solo tres meses más tarde se
estrellaba el avión de ethiopian y ahí
sí ante semejante escándalo y descrédito
la fea se vio obligada a paralizar toda
la flota del 73 y de máx hasta el día de
hoy
max
andy serkis max noáin
desgraciadamente ya era demasiado tarde
el daño ya estaba hecho cabecea no
reviso adecuadamente el sistema anti
pérdida del 737 max según hallazgos de
la jcr y ahora la pregunta es hasta
cuándo cuándo podrá volver a volar este
avión pues bien primero se dijo que era
inminente más tarde que para enero de
este 2009 estaría ya todo arreglado
ahora algunos dicen que para abril y
otros apuntan incluso que hasta finales
de año nada de nada
y ojo porque todos muchos analistas
piensan que las modificaciones de diseño
que habría que hacer tan profundas que
es cuestión incluso más tiempo
y mientras tanto boeing y todas las
compañías aéreas se compraron este
modelo están sufriendo unas
consecuencias económicas enormes
consecuencias que os vamos a contar
[Música]
la hemorragia del 737 max
amigos el 737 es el modelo estrella de
boeing es cada avión más vendido del
mundo desde que se lanzó la primera
familia en la década de 1960
desde entonces se han construido más de
10 mil 500 aviones de este modelo por
eso no es extraño que boeing tuviera más
de 50 mil millones de dólares en pedidos
del 737 max en el momento en el que se
ordenó la paralización total de la flota
50.000 millones que ahora están en el
aire las órdenes y opciones de compra se
han desplomado y las aerolíneas y los
intermediarios están lanzándose a los
brazos de airbús para conseguir aviones
lo antes posible
[Música]
incluso el bus no da abasto de todos los
pedidos que están recibiendo tenemos que
incluso si el 77 máx srl reintrodujera
no está claro que el modelo tenga el
éxito de los anteriores es evidente que
muchos pasajeros yo he incluido le hemos
cogido miedo a un avión estructuralmente
inestable normal no os parece y eso es
lo que explica que podamos leer noticias
como ésta
united dice que permitirá a los
pasajeros evitar los vuelos con el 737
max de momento el fabricante
norteamericano ya ha perdido al menos
nueve mil millones de dólares con esta
crisis y ojo porque podrían ser
muchísimos más al menos 30 mil millones
boeing suspende la producción del 737
max envuelto en acciones fatales es la
primera vez en 20 años que boeing
detiene la producción de un modelo pero
claro el fabricante tiene al menos 400
aviones ya fabricados que no puede
entregar ya ni siquiera tiene dónde
meterlos y algunos han acabado incluso
estacionados en el propio parking de
empleados de boeing y claro esta
decisión no sólo afecta a boeing ya sus
12.000 trabajadores
la fábrica de renton que construye el
737 max también afecta a alrededor de
600 empresas proveedoras mucho más
pequeñas que podrían tener problemas
económicos serios
el efecto dominó puede ser duro para la
economía estadounidense hay miles y
miles de puestos de trabajo en juego
algo que como os podéis imaginar ejerce
también una enorme presión sobre las
decisiones de la efe a la hora de
autorizar que el avión entre en servicio
lo antes posible y este este puede ser
uno de los motivos de la desconfianza
que se ha adueñado de algunas agencias
de seguridad aérea por ejemplo la casa
de europa que por primera vez ha roto
con una tradición de bilateralidad una
tradición por la cual si la efe ha
aprobaba un modelo de boeing este era
aprobado automáticamente por la easa y
viceversa en el caso de las aprobaciones
de aviones airbus sin embargo ahora
parece que eso ya no va a ser así
y
los reguladores aéreos europeos rompen
con el calendario de la efe para el 737
max
[Música]
y ojo porque el 2020 es toda una
incógnita os imagináis qué podría pasar
si el 737 max sigue sin volar el para lo
que podría suponer para el gigante
boeing y todo ello por no hablar de los
serios problemas que la empresa podría
estar teniendo con el desarrollo de su
otro nuevo modelo estrella el triple 7x
que de pronto le ha forzado a retrasar
su presentación las pruebas en el boing
triple 7x terminan con la explosión de
una puerta de carga según reuters el
fuselaje del boeing triple 7x
supuestamente se parte durante un test
de estrés en septiembre
la pregunta que ahora cada vez más
analistas se hacen es podría ser el caso
del 737 max tan solo el principio de un
problema a gran escala en las líneas de
desarrollo y producción de boeing podría
ser 2020 un año todavía peor para la
compañía norteamericana difícil saberlo
a ciencia cierta pero la cosa no pinta
nada bien desde aquí el diviso al
político estaremos atentos llegados a
este punto vos qué pensáis queréis
realista que se apruebe su entrada en
operaciones para abril de este año
después de paralizar boeing su
producción el pasado diciembre tendríais
la confianza suficiente como para volar
en un avión de este modelo como siempre
dejad vuestros comentarios aquí abajo y
si te ha resultado interesante este
vídeo no olvides darle al botón de like
suscribirte a visual polític para no
perderte nada de todo lo que está por
venir un saludo y hasta la próxima
max sartori ser max noáin